[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je
l'équipe du théâtre est ravi
d'accueillir pour la première fois
d'ailleurs les voeux la cérémonie de
voeux l'établissement public
d'aménagement barriques saclay soyez
donc toutes et tous les bienvenus
[Musique]
bienvenue me si bien sûr à saint quentin
qui fait partie de paris saclay au delà
bien sûr et le coeur économique de paris
saclay disent que nous avons 17 milles
entre brioude ses très belles quad qui
ont travaillé sur le sujet à ses côtés
du futur 2019 formaté années d'avancées
concrètes une année charnière pour
entamer une nouvelle décennie jusqu'en
2030 2030 qui est d'ailleurs l'année
d'achèvement programme mais de
l'ensemble de la ligne 18 du grand paris
express est la véritable colonne
vertébrale de ce territoire
sur les trois ans de nos ambitions du
projet 2010 a fait une étape importante
et a vu la vie urbaine prendre enfin
place sur le campus urbain du sud
plateau
effectivement après les étudiants et les
chercheurs et enseignants sont arrivés
les premiers habitants
les commerces sont aussi arrivés alors
les premiers sont pas les ont surgi sur
yvette d'arriver au printemps et on
arrive maintenant à sentir ce que
deviendra l'ensemble de ceux de ce
projet de ce campus urbain mix ils sont
français dans une vraie ambition urbaine
urbanistique pour le plateau afin d'y
faire ce que nous avions comme ambition
des bars c'est à dire un parc naturel
urbain
je rappelle que la nature devait être
vraiment au coeur de
la conception même du plateau et du
campus notre territoire doit aussi être
un laboratoire de la ville humaines de
la ville durable
on va voir une zone le moins artificiel
possible et il faut avoir une zone
d'émission négative donc on doit avoir
un campus à énergie positive
je voulais saluer tous les nouveaux
arrivants sur le plateau leur dire
bienvenue et leur dire que on est
extrêmement fier de les accueillir tous
on attend les les suivants avec bonheur
et aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a réussi à
vraiment accélérer le transfert
d'innovation et puis à donner envie aux
jeunes aussi créer leur entreprise à
saclay ce n'est pas du tout évident
cette année c'est les dix ans donc on se
retrouvera très vite pour se souhaiter
un très bel anniversaire et ce sera le
moment de faire vraiment le bilan de
tout ce qu'on a fait et philippe crois
que n'aurait pas à rougir du bilan que
vous arrivez à présenter mais s'il vous
plaît on plante encore quelques arbres
d'ici mois de mai et puis on essaye
d'ouvrir quelques commerces
voilà belle et heureuse année à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]